india has been and remains one of the
most religiously diverse regions in the
world
even a relatively unitary category like
hinduism known internally as sanatana
dharma
is really more of an umbrella term for a
whole variety of
different religious traditions the
philosophical or theological system
known as
vedanta is one of the most significant
aspects of this wider religious
tradition of hinduism
it took sacred scriptures like the
upanishads the brahma sutras
and the bhagavad-gita and created a very
sophisticated system of scriptural
exegesis that has become famous
to this day in a previous episode we've
already talked about the great
vedantic scholar shankara and his school
of
advaita vedanta or non-dual
vedanta today we will continue that
story by exploring another
sage and scholar within the larger
tradition of vedanta
a philosopher has become perhaps the
most significant for the devotional side
of hinduism
generally a fascinating sage
by the name of ramanuja
[Music]
ramanuja is a historical figure of great
renown in the hindu traditions of india
his philosophical system known as
vishishta dwight david
came to play a central role in the
history of shri vaishnavism
which is the school devoted to
worshipping vishnu as the supreme god
and which has perhaps been the majority
form of at least devotional hinduism
for most of history ramanuja belongs to
the philosophical tradition of vedanta
and
much of his ideas and philosophy is in
direct response to shankara and his
advaita vedanta
so in order to be able to fully grasp
and appreciate
the points made in this video and the
points made by
ramanuja himself i highly recommend and
suggest you go and watch some of my
previous episodes
on vedanta and on shankar in particular
before
you watch this one and then come back to
this one now the life of ramanura is as
usual
hard to get at with certainty just like
with shankara the biographical material
we have
comes from hagiographies and should be
read with a healthy level of skepticism
but as always situating a person in his
environment is very helpful
in order to grasp his ideas and their
context more properly
these traditional accounts tell of how
ramanuja was born into a brahmana
or priestly family in southern india
close to the modern city of madras which
is also known as
chennai his birth year isn't necessarily
agreed upon
but with the traditional accounts
placing it in 1017
there are others who believe it may have
been around the year
10 77 but we can at least be pretty
certain
that he lived during the 11th to 12th
centuries ramanuja appears to have grown
up in a tamil environment that was
strongly infused with
devotional fervor for the god vishnu
represented for example by the so-called
al-war saints
were poet saints of southern india who
expressed a strong
devotion or bhakti towards vishnu in
particular
this environment seems to have strongly
influenced ramanuja's religious and
philosophical leanings as we will see
in any case he is said to have started
to study vedanta at some point
under a teacher called yadava who had a
very strong leaning towards the advaitha
or
non-dual interpretation of shankara in
particular
being a very gifted man already in his
youth
ramanuja is said to have disagreed with
his teacher on a number of points
he disagreed with the impersonal static
view of god or brahman
expressed in advaita vedanta preferring
instead a more personal god
that could be worshiped one story tells
of how ramanuja began to cry
as yadava prakasha offered a upanishadic
interpretation that seemed in a classic
non-dualist term
to equate the brahman with created
things
like monkeys in this particular case
when the teacher confronted him
ramanuda offered a
counter-interpretation that retained the
transcendence of the brahmana
these tensions between the teacher and
student eventually led to their split
ramanuja going his own way basically
there are even stories of how the
teacher yada pakasha
attempted to have ramanujan murdered at
some point which
tells us that the tensions were probably
pretty high
later ramanuja instead became associated
with two
other teachers yamuna and mahapurna both
associated with the
vaisnava's tradition of bhakti devotion
and he was eventually initiated into
shrivaisnavism himself
he then became a significant authority
figure within the larger vaisnavite
community at the time
serving as priest in several important
vishnu temples
around india particularly in southern
india he seems to have caught the
attention of a lot of
people due to his intellectual
capabilities he seems to have been a
very
gifted man he seems to have also caught
the attention of people because he
appears to have criticized or been
critical towards
certain aspects of the caste system
there are stories of how ramanuja would
treat people of the lowest caste
should request on equal terms
which was pretty unusual at that time
especially and also that he taught
that anyone who showed sincere devotion
to vishnu regardless of caste
could reach liberation which is also
quite an unusual teaching at that time
like so many others of his kind
including shankara as we saw
it is told how ramanuja when he wasn't
busy being a priest in one of the vishnu
temples
would travel all around india seeking
philosophical or or spiritual knowledge
and also debating people from opposing
philosophical schools
of course the tradition also tells us
how he completely defeated
all of them uh with his skills in
rhetoric
and in our argumentation during his life
ramanujan managed to leave a lasting
mark on the history of hinduism
just like with his birth the date of his
death is somewhat contested but the
traditional account is that he lived
between
10 17 to 11 37
which would have made him 120 years old
by his
death there are more conservative
estimates by
modern scholars who suggest that the
years 1077 to 1157
might be more accurate for his life in
any case he seems to have definitely
lived a
long life regardless of which of these
perspectives you choose to to believe in
and in that very long life he showed his
intellectual skills by writing
many works of treatises and books
on the philosophy of vedanta and
vedantic philosophy
just like all other such philosophers of
that school
the majority of those texts include
commentaries on the core text of vedanta
so
he wrote for example a commentary called
the basha
on the bhagavad-gita and also what is
probably his most important and famous
work which is known as the sri basia
which is a commentary on the brahma
sutras and all these writings really
reflect the general
mission and purpose of ramanuja's whole
career basically that is the
harmonization
of the bhakti tradition of devotion to
vishnu
which was so popular particularly in
southern india at this time
with the upanishads the the great vedic
texts
and their exegetical tradition in other
words with vedanta
the philosophical or theological
tradition of vedanta
is primarily concerned with three core
texts
firstly there's the upanishads which is
usually considered a part of the larger
corpus of the vedas there is also the
brahma sutras which is a
kind of commentary on the upanishads and
then lastly there is the very famous
bhagavad-gita
which features the god krishna and his
dialogue with the warrior arjuna
for those of you who ignored my earlier
suggestion to check out the earlier
episodes first
we could say that these primary textual
sources and thus
vedanta as a philosophical tradition is
primarily concerned with a few different
concepts and their relationships to each
other
perhaps the most central of these is the
concept of brahman
which is conceived of as the absolute
reality that underlies
all of the universe all pervading one
and ineffable
the brahman is not only the center point
of existence
but also of vedanta there is also the
important concept of the
atma or self both in terms of a
universal kind of self
above all individuality but also the
individual selves or souls of human
beings
more commonly called the jiva or jivatma
now these concepts
so brahman atman jiva etc
are always very central aspects of
vedanta
but different schools interpret their
relationship in different ways
as we saw in the episode on shankara and
advaita vedanta
this school interprets the text in
non-dual terms
the atman the individual selves and
really all of the world
is identical to the brahman they are the
very same thing
and all appearance of multiplicity or
difference
is the result of ignorance known as
avidya
and of illusion called maya while being
highly influenced by it
ramanuja is highly critical of shankara
and other proponents of advaita vedanta
or non-dualistic vedanta
who argued for the absolute identity of
the individual self and the brahman or
absolute reality
this approach he felt rendered
devotional practice unnecessary
which was unthinkable to him instead
ramanuja tries to show
how the upanishads and the bhagavad-gita
really argues that
bhakti or devotion is the true path to
liberation
and to do so he needs to present a quite
different interpretation where he
diverges from the interpretations of
advaitha
on a number of central points and it is
thus to the ideas and teachings of
ramanuja that we now turn as i've
already mentioned the philosophical
system that he is associated
with is called vishisht advaitha which
is usually translated as
qualified non-dualism as opposed to just
advaita which simply means non-dualism
as the name suggests vishishta dwayta
takes some of the basic features of
advaita
and retains a certain form of monism or
non-dualism but
modifies it in ways that allows for a
more personal relationship
and approach to god and worship in
vishishtadvaita the concept of brahman
or absolute reality
is directly identified as vishnu or
narayana the supreme god of vaishnavism
thus ramanuja denies the advaithi
concept of nirguna brahman
there is brahman without attributes
instead he argues that brahman or vishnu
in other words
is ultimately a personal deity with
attributes
sometimes known as saguna brahman it is
very important for ramanuja to uphold
the relevance of personal worship
and thus to retain a transcendence of
god from human beings
for this reason he also rejects the
non-dualist claim
that the world of multiplicity and
change is the result of avidya or
ignorance or maya
instead ramanuja is a realist the
created world including the diversity
and multiplicity within it
is essentially real quote
next to the assertion that all
difference presented in our cognition as
of jars pieces of cloth and the like
is unreal because such difference does
not persist
this view we maintain is altogether
erroneous
in other words the world and the
individual self the atman
is not identical to the brahman
each self is an individual self with a
consciousness of his own
ramanuja divides things into three
essential and distinct categories
a chit which is non-conscious entities
and objects of perception
in other words matter basically then
there's chit
which is conscious individual selves or
souls and lastly there is brahman
who is also identified as we saw as the
god vishnu or
as we can see already ramanujan
maintains a clear distinction between
god and the world or individual selves
but at the same time to him god is also
the underlying reality of all that
exists
it's god is kind of their very substance
but as opposed to advaita vedanta which
posits that the brahman and the
individual self or the world is
completely identical to each other
being no difference at all to ramanuja
instead
the individual self or the world could
be seen as
god's body and god being the soul
which controls that body in the words of
c.j bartley quote
the scriptures correctly interpreted
definitely state that the conscious and
non-conscious entities
in all their states as subjects and
objects of experience
are ensoled by the supreme person who is
their underlying reality
and incapable of existence independently
of him
this is because they are controlled by
the supreme person
insofar as they constitute his body the
supreme person
of whom the conscious and unconscious
substantial entities are existentially
dependent
modes since they constitute his body
exist
imminently in the form of the universe
in its potential and actual conditions
chit and achit entities are real and
identifiable
only by virtue of being modes of the
brahman
in other words the world and its
conscious and unconscious entities
are in god and are entirely dependent on
him for their existence
but are not completely identical to him
he remains
transcendent and beyond the limitations
of created things
while also remaining their very
underlying reality and substance
what some would call a kind of
pan-antheism
this is what ramanuja himself has to say
in the shri basia quote
any substance that a conscious entity
can control and support entirely for its
own purposes
and whose sole essence is to be an
ancillary to that entity
is its body therefore all conscious and
non-conscious entities
are the body of the supreme person since
they are controlled and supported by him
entirely for his own purposes
and their soul essence is to be his
ancillaries
so there is no maya or grand illusion
according to
ramanuja no avidya or ignorance that
causes us to misunderstand the realities
of things
the world is real and it is different
from god
who still remains the world's underlying
reality
in fact he very harshly criticizes the
idea of avidya or
ignorance that the advaita vedantin so
hold on so dearly to he sees it as
completely contradictory
if it is true as they say that
everything is completely identical to
the brahman
then where does ignorance come from that
means that ignorance must be part of the
brahman
if everything is identical to the
brahman and so that would
neglect or compromise the perfection
of the brahman which is part of of one
of its
one of the ways that it is described
it's it's it's complete it can have no
it can have no imperfections basically
and so he
very cleverly argues that the idea of
avidya goes against the very
foundational ideas
of what the brahman is supposed to be
and thus the advaitans according to him
they self-contradict themselves instead
seeks to find a solution where god is
unified and
one with creation or with the world but
that he still remains unaffected by its
corruptions
and this is why the metaphor of the
soul-body relationship works so well
here
it is interesting that ramanuja is
working from the very same sources
he's reading the same text that the
advaitans are reading
but he's interpreting them in completely
different ways it's a good example to
show how texts bear
very little meaning without an external
person who interacts and interprets
those texts indeed when we read text
like the upanishads
at least from a certain perspective they
can appear to contradict themselves
there are sections that certainly appear
non-dualistic or as monistic
and those of course are the sections
that people like shankara
hold on to so dearly but at the same
time there are examples of
other sections that give us a completely
different view of reality sometimes much
more
theistic and dualistic etc ramanuja
recognized these seeming contradictions
and tried to offer an exegesis
that took all of the different aspects
into consideration
the seemingly non-dual sections can be
harmonized with more
theistic expressions in a grand system
that incorporates
all of these perspectives and this is
vishishtadvaita or qualified non-dualism
now even though ramanuja clearly
disagrees with advaita vedanta on a
number of points
he's definitely inspired by earlier
writers like shankara
and does indeed share some of their
ideas he agrees with them in stating
that the only true means of true
knowledge in terms of ultimate truths of
the brahman which is also known as the
pramana
means to knowledge is sacred scriptures
that is the vedas
upanishads bhagavad-gita and the
brahma-sutras
quote because brahman being raised above
all contact with the senses
is not an object of perception and the
other means of proof
but to be known through scripture only
but in many other respects as we have
seen his positions are
very different and all of this stems
obviously from his
strong insistence on retaining the
importance
of prayers and personal worship devotion
bhakti in other words to a deity
to a personal god with attributes
he felt that the system of advaita
vedanta
made prayers and rituals useless because
if we are identical to god if i am god
what's the purpose of praying to god for
all of hinduism in general and
therefore also for vedanta in particular
the ultimate goal
of life in general is to reach
moksha in other words liberation from
the constant cycle of
rebirths that the soul goes through
and in advaita vedanta the
path to liberation that is most
emphasized the
one true path in in a sense to this
liberation
is what is known as jnana yoga or the
yoga of
knowledge what this means is that
in order to reach liberation we are to
reach knowledge of our true selves
we have to recognize and realize that
our individual self is a form of
illusion that
my true nature is identical to
the brahman to absolute reality there is
no difference between us
and all experience of difference between
myself for anything and the brahman any
appearance of multiplicity
is a misunderstanding it's a
superimposition
that is ultimately not real so to reach
liberation according to advaita vedanta
is to is through reaching knowledge of
this essential reality of ourselves
but ramanuja and vishishta dwayta
disagree with this
the only true path to liberation for
them is
bhakti yoga the yoga of devotion
it is not by reaching knowledge of our
true selves that we are liberated
but through the grace of god or vishnu
as a result of our sincere devotion to
him
quote it was also shown that knowledge
vision and the attainment of the lord
can be had only through one pointed and
absolute devotion
this devotion is to be done through
things like prayers offerings and the
many rituals performed in the temples
dedicated to the gods
such as puja the famous ritual when food
and other items are offered to the image
of a deity
a general personal pity and devotion
directly to vishnu as a deity with
attributes
filled with love and grace that can be
bestowed upon the worshipper indeed
was after all a priest in an important
vishnu temple
and we see him strongly incorporating
that into his reading
of the upanishads it is also for this
reason that he rejects the idea of the
attributeless brahman
so emphasized by advaita brahman is not
static but a personal deity with
attributes who controls the world as his
body
quote all things in the world whether
they are or are not
our vishnu's body and he is their soul
just like the body and soul are
intimately connected and unified
the body being dependent on the soul so
the world is unified to
and existentially dependent on vishnu or
narayana
and just as it is the duty of the body
to obey and
serve the soul so it is the duty of us
as creatures to serve
god the individual selves of the world
are not totally unified as a single
consciousness their
individuality being illusions but
independently distinct selves
albeit all being part of the self of god
or modes or outer expressions of that
god
it's hard to talk about the ramanuja in
this way without making
constant comparisons and references to
other schools of vedanta
primarily advaita but this is because so
many of ramanuja's ideas are in direct
response and in conversation with that
school
i could sit here all day and point out
the different particularities of
philosophical doctrines where he differs
from other schools but
i think the aspects that we have talked
about so far
make up the core features and
characteristics of his system
and how it fits into the wider tradition
of vedanta
the influence of ramanuja has been
immense
arguably in the history of hinduism he
managed to surpass
shankara in terms of influence by taking
the popular devotional tradition of
vaishnavism
that form of religious practice so
popular among the majority
population and giving it a firm
philosophical
theological intellectual and scriptural
basis
grounded in the vedas he created an
incredibly successful and lasting school
of thought
that has remained one of the
cornerstones of hindu devotion
to this day vaishnavism and hinduism
wouldn't be what it is without the
influence of ramanuja
he might not be as famous as shankara
advaita vedanta and shankar after all
has become very famous in the western
world as one of the
the most featured aspects of the
category of eastern wisdoms but in
native india
ramanuja and his vishishta has provided
a
theistic form of devotional practice
that is still
also very strongly connected to the
philosophical
sophistication and argumentation of
vedanta
he is often called the single most
important thinker
in all of devotional hinduism for these
reasons
ramanuja should definitely be considered
one of the most significant and
important thinkers in the history of the
world
his intellectual brilliance reaches us
even today when we read his works
just the fact that he challenged the
great shankara and in the process
managed to actually give him a run for
his money should be enough to merit our
admiration
i hope you've enjoyed this video if you
want to support this channel and its
attempts to give you
uh scholarly and academic
content about the world's different
religious traditions you can support us
on patreon through a monthly donation
special shout out to
ccb6b3252ee
33c8 thank you for making me say that
out loud
or through a one-time donation on paypal
and you can also of course just like the
video subscribe to the channel
and keep the discussion going in the
comments and i'll see you next time
you